what did you think feel and pray for in
the days that followed October
7th I think the
first feeling was
that uh there's going to be a lot of
death and destruction in Gaza as a
result right we always kind of see this
where one is really casualty leads to
hundreds of Palestinian casualties right
so it's a pretty familiar cycle in some
ways where there are daily
transgressions against Palestinians in
the West Bank and in Gaza the
checkpoints the aggression on masj
AA the settlements
expanding the stories of Palestinian
death and then you have Rockets fired
from Gaza and that's when the Western
press catches up and starts to cover it
Israel responds with Hellfire missile
fight phosphorous bombs and the
casualties are wildly
disproportionate and so I think that you
know I wasn't surprised I prayed for the
people that I knew were going to Bear
the
brunt of this outbreak but the outbreak
was
predictable you wrote a statement on
October 9th I was hoping uh to read it
if it's okay yeah go ahead our pales Ian
casualties are always your footnotes the
daily humiliation of occupation ignored
the aggression by settlers and soldiers
alike on holy sights and
souls the annihilation of entire
families that follows the devastation of
whatever scraps remain in the open air
prison of Gaza unsustainable and
inhumane so if you're waking up to a
sudden interest in the region and want
to know what's been happening dig a bit
deeper than two weeks and and try to
read beyond the headlines of a media
that has been dehumanizing us for
decades again this was not surprising
this was very predictable if you've been
watching what's been unfolding before
October 7th
20121 Human Rights Watch puts out the
report threshold reached Israel is an
apartheid state Amnesty International
2022 the crime of
aparte uh showing how all of the legal
determinations of apartheid have been
reached the occupation is only getting
more aggressive Shireen abaka a
Palestinian American journalist is shot
dead in
2022 in front of the world the United
States says initially that if it is
shown that Israel was complicit or that
Israel carried out the execution then
there will be
consequences of course once it was shown
that Israel was indeed responsible
for the bullet that killed Shireen abaka
the United States did absolutely nothing
shireen's funeral was attacked the
powars were beaten her casket almost
fell and again the world is watching the
aggression
against worshippers and AKA is getting
worse you have the flag March the
Jerusalem flag March where extremist
settlers are let loose and Wild on
Palestinians by the thousands chanting
things like Muhammad is dead we're going
to murder you Arabs all with the
protection of the state with Israeli
soldiers and throughout this time it's
like something bad is going to happen
and then 2023 comes
along you had 13,000 settler
units in
2023 a plan of 13,000 settler units the
most in the history of the occupation
the most racist and extreme government
Israeli government that you have ever
had and people don't realize that in
2023 alone over 600 Palestinians had
already been killed it just doesn't make
western headlines and so if you wonder
why the American public sees this so
much differently than the rest of the
world it's because American media shows
the American public something so much
different than what the rest of the
world has shown and so this was a
pressure cooker
this was going to explode it is
extremely predictable you've given
people absolutely no hope and so I I
think that as we're watching that you
know it's important for us to actually
interogate the
ignorance that people have of the
Palestinian plight the ignorance of the
root causes of this violence the
ignorance of the
occupation and also ask yourselves you
know why is it that Israel can violate
every single international law on the
books have all these determinations and
the United States keeps on issuing these
inconsequential statements while also at
the same time funding these aggressions
so it's like stop the settler violence
the United States will issue statement
after statement stop the settler
violence stop the incursions on
stop violating the people in Jerusalem
stop trying to wipe out the Palestinian
people stop openly saying you know that
there is no two-state solution that we
will never allow a Palestinian state to
be established but at the same time
here's your $3 billion check and uh if
the United Nations issues any sort of
resolution against Israel or if any
International body tries to hold Israel
accountable the United States stands in
the the way of any accountability it's
important for us to ask why and so I
always tell people read beyond the
headlines even now with the backdrop of
a genocide over 30,000 people have been
killed if you open the front page of
most American mainstream sites you will
see stories about the hostages the
Israeli hostages you will see stories
about October 7th but October 8th is
missing October 9th is missing October
10th is missing a 100 days of genocide
are missing
and you'll barely have a story that
shows up every once in a while that you
know is still very much so controlled by
the Israeli propaganda machine because
while Israel kills Palestinian
journalists it also makes sure that
American journalists are only able to
tell a certain story they're only able
to see Gaza from a certain perspective
they're only able to speak about Gaza
from a certain perspective and this is
well documented that they have to review
their media tapes with Israel before
they can publicize them and so this is
State propaganda at this point the
mainstream media and the United States
government are in lock step telling a
very skewed story and that is leading to
a greater sense of frustration and I
think the American public has been
wronged as well by not knowing what's
happening so you mentioned settlements
so to you this is bigger than Gaza it is
the West Bank it is the the P inan
people broadly absolutely you can't
disconnect Gaza from Palestine you can't
disconnect the West Bank from Palestine
you can't disconnect Jerusalem from
Palestine and you can't disconnect the
very human story from the political
plight you interviewed Muhammad Al Kur
you met him what did the world do when
it saw the images of the Kur houseold
being taken over by a guy from Brooklyn
or Long Island who just shows up and
claim to their home what did the world
do when American
settlers suddenly decided they could
walk into historic Palestinian homes and
throw people out of their homes what did
the world do and so yes this is very
much so connected to the broader issue
of Palestinian existence if you realize
here we are erased in peace and we are
erased in war in peace it's the Abraham
Accords agreements between Israel and
its Arab Neighbors which is supposedly
to solve the Palestinian problem the
Palestinians are absent from their own
fate from discussions about their own
fate in war it's the Israel Hamas War
it's Israel and Gaza where are the
Palestinian people the millions of
Palestinian people that have either been
removed from their land or are being
tormented on their land where are they
in this discussion what are the
Palestinians in the diaspora
feeling I think deeply
frustrated a great sense of anger
sadness every single Palestinian right
now knows someone that's been killed
every single Palestinian is a part of a
story of displacement or destruction
every single Palestinian has a relative
that's either missing a limb or a loved
one every single Palestinian in the
world is traumatized by
this and in some ways being
outside of Palestine being away from it
all hurts even more because you see your
people being killed and starved and
brutalized and slaughtered and you can't
do anything about it and the people
around you are justifying that Slaughter
if you turn on a TV or if you open a
mainstream news site these sites are
just justifying your Slaughter and
people are being killed over there
because they look like me because
they're Palestinian like I'm Palestinian
and so we're watching this in diaspora
uh with Agony we can't go we can't we
can't heal our loved ones we can't
Comfort the people that are there I
recently spoke to a doctor who's lost 75
relatives 75 relatives in Gaza and he's
a medical
doctor and all he wants to do is get in
there and just use his medical expertise
to help his people and he can't and so
we're watching it from afar but our
hearts are there they are in the
buildings that are being destroyed
they're in the hospitals that are being
bombed they are there and they are with
the people you're somebody who's always
rushed into the midst of a
crisis so what does it feel like on a
personal level to not be able to do that
here to go to Gaza to
help yeah
it's it's really hard I mean when any
group of people are
killed
uh my instinct and I think a lot of
people is to go there to help whether
it's a natural disaster or especially
after an incident of Terror um wherever
it is right it's Rush there and do the
best that you can to help people get
through it um so it's
been extremely hard uh to watch this
from afar and feel like I can't do
anything about it and so that's why
instead I think that uh most of us are
driven to continue to be the voice of
the voiceless you know I always say that
if they've made them faceless they can't
make us
voiceless they have reduced our
casualties in Palestine to a number the
number is
hundreds a day over 30,000 people we're
averaging 10,000 people a month the fact
that they've been turned into faceless
numbers with no stories with no Humanity
makes it that much more important for us
to tell their stories here and to remind
the world that you've lost your Humanity
if you can watch this unfold and not
even have the decency to call for a
ceasefire I mean that's the that's where
we've reached that's how low it is right
now calling for a
ceasefire has now become radical uh so
we have to remind the world that if
you're okay with the Demolition of an
entire town or a city or whatever it is
that you want to call Gaza because it
wasn't always the Gaza Strip but if
you're okay with this and you're okay
with this casualty count every single
day it's not just them who are being
killed it's your hearts that are dying
and I think that when I look back to Dr
Martin Luther King Jr and I I mentioned
this he wrote about Vietnam he said that
if America was to succumb to uh its
spiritual death the autopsy would read
Vietnam I would say that it would read
Gaza
now